hey i'm haley steinfeld and i play emily
dickinson hi
i'm ella hunt and i play sue hey i'm
adrian blake ensco and i play austin
hi i'm anna bershnikov and i play
lavinia dickinson
hi i'm jane krakowski and i play mrs
dickinson we are here with buzzfeed
today to find out which character
we actually are
[Music]
what was your favorite subject in school
english art math history
science foreign language foreign
language come on
i picked the only one i could probably
pass which was art
okay i picked math uh you picked math
yeah i liked it i didn't understand it
but i enjoyed it i just was that kid
who always like shot their hand up the
minute the teacher was like
who wants to read aloud today
ella i feel like you have an unfair
advantage with english because i'm
english
because you are english i picked history
because i was a young
scholar i guess i picked foreign
language because
i'm just a romantic at heart give us a
sentence of yours do you speak anything
foreign
wow which diggins in character would you
trust
with a secret george gold maggie
edward dickinson ben newton jane
humphrey
death interesting i'm torn between death
and ben
they're both deaf basically so your
secret is pretty
tightly secured right my initial impulse
was death
but i don't trust him so i'm going with
ben i think so too
i have to say george gold because samuel
is my buddy in real life and
you know i would die that's why i was so
tempted to go with jane humphrey because
i would go to gus with any kind of
secret
but i know that jane humphrey would be
an atrocious
secret keeper i went with ben i think
ben
is an ethical good soul at the end of
the day
i think i'm gonna go with my instinct so
ben i too went with ben
choose a classic novel to read alice in
wonderland
of mice and men wuthering heights
little women pride and prejudice to kill
a mockingbird
well i'm gonna go with my true soul
because wuthering heights
is one of my favorite books i'm going
with to kill mockingbird
nice i'm going with pride and prejudice
i'm gonna say alice
in wonderland let's get wacky and i
picked little women we all picked
different ones
pick a book adaptation to watch oh so
we're staying literary i like it
the hunger games we got watchmen the
perks of being a wallflower
normal people game of thrones and
it i'm going with normal people because
daisy who plays marianne
is my best friend and we played twins
it was like our first big job ever and
we played twins and i love her
normal people is one thousand percent
the lavinian choice
i know that i gotta go with watchmen
because i read that comic book this year
and it was
gorgeous it's awesome i'm gonna say
watchmen too i pick normal people
because it's on my current watch list to
actually watch
i'm going with the hunger games i don't
know where that leads me
to dickinson but it's kind of where i'm
at currently
in my brain so i'm going i'm going with
hunger games choose a song to sing at
karaoke
i want it that way by the backstreet
boys shake it off by taylor swift
umbrella by rihanna thank you next by
ariana grande don't stop believing by
journey or dancing queen by abba dancing
queen
i'm going with umbrella by rihanna i was
also thinking of going up
with umbrella but i was teased horribly
in school
about umbrella because because it goes
umbrella ella
ella and people would sing it at me
the whole time i love umbrella but i'm
gonna i'm gonna go
old school i'm gonna go don't stop
believing by sure
perfect i think i'm gonna go thank you
next i'm gonna do shake it off by taylor
swift come on guys that's a good one
that's a good one and finally choose an
emily dickinson
quote bring me the sunset in a cup
forever is composed of nouns mourning
without you
is a dwindled dawn i dwell in
possibility
saying nothing sometimes says the most i
think
i'm gonna go with dwell in possibility
because that's what we need
i'm also gonna go with i dwell in
possibility because that just
struck a chord with me right now but as
lavinia i think it's bring me the sunset
in a cup
that's the one i was gonna pick i'm so
lavidia
i think i'm gonna go with forever is
composed of now's
that just how very zen of you i'm going
with saying nothing sometimes says the
most
and the real emily dickinson is you're
emily davidson
oh no he's gonna get fired i got sue
so sick i got mrs dickinson
i didn't get lavinia i got emily
dickinson
which i'm stoked about because anna
knows but lavinia is like my favorite
character so this is exciting moment for
me
your personality matches lavinia you're
compassionate earnest and witty like
lavinia you're someone who loves to have
a good time
you're a hopeless romantic who still
believes the one is out there somewhere
you wear your heart on your sleeve you
won't stop until your dreams come true
that's amazing thank you so much
buzzfeed uh
we cannot wait for you to see season two
of dickinson january 8th
we love you guys and now let's do an
episode where we play the characters we
were meant to be through buzzfeed
you